[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the 2018
edition of one of the greatest
tournaments in the world
the Sinquefield Cup I'm your host
Maurice Ashley and I'm happy to be here
first of all I want to thank Shannon
Bailey and the world chess Hall of Fame
for hosting this event it is a
spectacular venue and we always
appreciate the work that her and her
staff puts in the police thank you very
much give her a warm welcome tonight
[Applause]
there are people who really need no
introduction their generosity has been
simply amazing the folks who make this
all possible the miracle here in st.
Louis we absolutely want to thank dr.
Jeanne sing field and a rec sing field
please give them a hand
there's a visionary not here I keep
saying his name and you could say it
over and over and not really exhaust the
greatness that is this man he has been
he was world champion for many years the
number one player for 20 and he has
continued to be a great visionary for
the game of chess and having conceived
at the Grantchester and here's an
indefatigable work that has made all of
this possible we want to thank wherever
he is Gary Kasparov they are also people
behind the scenes who do work for the
Grantchester the ones who conceived of
this new format which has been very
exciting for us this year which will
culminate with this final leg and then
of course London I hear that they
already figured out the dates and and
the format for London and that will be
announced next week but I want to thank
Mike Karthik offski tawny rich Graham
Jorgensen and also Malcolm Payne in
London thank you very much for all your
tireless efforts three legs are complete
for the tour three legs the first one we
had was in Levin that was won by
Grandmaster
Wesley so and we want to thank my young
killer heart and your next move for
their efforts yawn I know you're
watching thank you so much
and in the Paris leg which was won by
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura
Jill Beth Hauser with Colliers
International and also Vivendi and all
the other sponsors who make that into a
marvelous event thank you as well
[Applause]
and the third leg we just saw conclude
just a couple of days ago and it just
feels like yeah I don't even know what
to say about it frankly but the
commentary we were so excited you guys
kept us on the edges of our seats it was
fantastic it was exciting all the way to
the end finally won in the
second-to-last round of the blitz and we
once again want to congratulate
Grandmaster Cara Nakamura on a
spectacular victory but it's time for
the Ziegfeld Cup and before we move
along I'd like to introduce the
executive director of the Chess Club
Tony rich Thank You Maurice so I
mentioned at the closing ceremony for
the st. Louis rapid in blitz that the
Chess Club has been open for 10 years
now well 20 years ago I actually ran my
very first Chess Club that we're just
pawns Club we met at a book store I'd
set out the coffee can for donations I'd
set up the folding chairs and tables you
know whenever we get 50 bucks and they
can we be able to buy a new clock for
the club it was great really but you
know being a chess fan for my whole life
seeing these top players here has always
been my dream and now it's a dream come
true this is the fifth year now that
we've been able to host this thing field
cup in st. Louis I've had the
opportunity not just to meet these
players but get to know them and I can
tell you that they they live up to the
reputation of being fierce competitors
true sportsman of the game and and true
gentleman as well so a big round for the
players I really appreciate all
[Applause]
a little bit on the technical side just
to give you an idea of what the
Sinquefield cup will entail for the non
chess players out there the format is a
10 player round-robin which means
everyone plays everybody one time it's
not elimination or anything like that so
at the end of the nine rounds the player
with the most points will be crowned the
C field Cup champion take home the
$75,000 first-place prize as well as the
coveted Singh field cup here so you'll
see some exciting chess over the next
couple of weeks in addition to some
excellent production we have grandmaster
commentary provided by Alejandro Ramirez
and Christian Trillo a kingside diner
for a live audience
[Applause]
we have Russian commentary with Afghani
morash tischenko and Peter Svidler and
our English broadcast commentary team
the veterans of st. Louis commentary
yasser sarah juan Jennifer Shahade E and
Maurice Ashley so make sure you tune in
to Grantchester org to check out all the
commentary the games begin live at one
o'clock each day thank you all very much
Thank You Toby
[Applause]
well as I mentioned person who needs no
introduction as her generosity along
with her husband has been absolutely
phenomenal and instrumental in making
our magic here happen I'd like to
introduce dr. Jeannie Ziegfeld isn't
this a wonderful group are the best
players in the world look at this whoa I
can't imagine my husband now they'd the
clerk about why this was named after
Sinquefield was Rex did not want this to
be named the same field cup but I figure
if I'm paying for it why not and and Rex
has done a spectacular job of the best
players in the world so I'm just gonna
give a shout out to maybe some of those
out there in the hundred and ninety two
countries that are watching this
tournament and 190 thousand Boy Scouts
over in the chest merit badge
these are your heroes and this is the
godfather of American chess Rex
Sinquefield
Thanks well Jeannie's right I didn't
want to call the sink field cup so now
you know how much my vote counts so well
it's a wonderful time to welcome these
tremendous players to think Willis I
don't think any sport that Americans
enjoy has ever had ten top players in
one place as chess has done repeatedly
in st. Louis and it's a wonderful thing
and like Tony and others I want to thank
our broadcast team Jennifer Yasir
Maurice Harry Carey and Jack buck and
Peter Miro Christian Alejandro and then
Randy and his team at Spectrum 'gta and
the crew at silverback and Tammy Moses
Oh Leonard all of you do an amazing job
make the broadcast come to life come
alive in over 200 countries and the
staff and the Hall of Fame staff just
worked together so well and do a
incredible job and we're grateful to all
of you for everything you do and
everything you do is truly amazing
now as you most of you know we started
selling the Sinquefield Cup
celebrating five years and I'd like to
thank Paige Peterson who designed the
book and Emily Allred who was the
project manager they have done a
spectacular job
[Applause]
I also of course want to thank the
author's jennifer yasser maurice
alejandro and Tata this is probably
yasser 65th book you know something now
as some of you know who were watching
ultimate moves if you could stomach that
as I sometimes try to play the Sicilian
it turns out that today this date 60
years ago this day was the day that
Bobby Fischer in the 1958 quarter rolls
into inter-zonal
played bent Larsen where Larsen played
the dragon Sicilian and you all know
Bobby Fischer's famous phrase I had it
down to a science probably opened the
king rook file sex act mate yeah well I
didn't do it that well I'm sure she's
probably turning over in his grave given
the way we played it so now it's my
pleasure to introduce one of my favorite
and our favorite public officials the
finest county executive in the United
States the Honorable Steve stinger
[Applause]
I had no idea but thank you thank you
thank you all very much and welcome to
the 2018 Ziegfeld Cup we take a
tremendous amount of pride in our
region's official designation as the
chess capital of the world and in light
of the large number of visitors who have
attended previous chess championships
here it is easy to see how the st. Louis
area benefits from his standing as the
epicentre of chess that standing is
indeed resonating worldwide thanks to
the webcasting of this tournament and as
a stop on the grand chest tour the name
of st. Louis joins those of great world
capitals on the tour including Brussels
Paris and London I salute the Chess Club
and scholastic Center of st. Louis for
its ongoing advocacy of this great game
and I especially thank Rex and Jeanne
Ziegfeld for their sponsorship of this
tournament and for all they have done to
promote chess and our hometown thank you
again and it's great to be here thank
you thank you sue well much of what
happens here it's not solely about these
players as much as we idolize them and
recognize their genius it really is
about the many scholastic players young
players out there who look up to them
today the autograph session was packed
and we saw so many young kids were
excited to get the autographs of these
geniuses and the person who's a steward
of those youngsters and everything that
is chess in the United States I'd like
you to welcome the head of the US Chess
Federation Caroline
good evening everyone it's a real honor
to be here among the world's best chess
players at the at this stop along the
Grantchester the every time I come to
st. Louis I'm struck by the the vision
that Rex and Jeanne had to make st.
Louis what it's become and chess is in
every corner of this area of town and I
was in a store earlier today and someone
asked me what brought me to town and and
the clerk who who sold me something
remarked about how much you both have
done for this this city so I think again
I know a lot of people have already said
it but without without your vision none
of us would be here today and thank you
for all you do I also want to give a
shout out to the club the st. Louis
chess club and the Hall of Fame and
being new to this world not just a chess
but but although all of you I've really
been touched by the the opportunities
that you know joy and Tony and Shannon
have given to us chess to collaborate
and and I think we're really excited
about those opportunities to pursue
things together that that are good for
both the folks here in st. Louis as well
as us chess across the nation so thank
you for your support
I wasn't expecting to have to do this
this evening Chris bird can you come on
up
Chris might not be expecting this either
Chris was in the UK during the the
recent US Open and during our awards
ceremony there Chris would have been
presented with the tournament director
of the Year award from US chess and many
of you know that that Chris is the chief
arbiter for the the Sinquefield Cup this
week and and Chris I know you had very
humble beginnings with your your chess
game Chris shared with us that his first
chess set was done with his sister's
mascara pencil or work yeah so and cut
out pieces of paper for the the pieces
and you know he started playing
competitively sometime thereafter but
then really found his passion as a
tournament director and last year you
know before getting to do the
Sinquefield Cup here
he was the chief tournament director of
the largest super Nationals ever so
Chris congratulations in it from u.s.
chess thank you
[Applause]
thank you God and now it's my honor to
introduce the players we have a stellar
line-up and we said that last week but
the addition of another elements has
made this even exponentially greater and
we are honored to have this particular
lineup as the simply simply looks like
murderers row and these are as bad as
chess assassins can get you don't want
to mess with any one of these guys and I
would like to introduce them we have
already talked about their greatness and
their many accolades so I will simply
introduce them by name and I will start
at this end and come back first from
Azerbaijan chakra Mama's here off
[Applause]
from India this one on
[Applause]
from the united states we saw from
friends Maxine McGraw
[Music]
[Applause]
from Russia
Alexander Briscoe
boom Armenia LaVon
[Applause]
from russia sergey belyakovitch
[Applause]
from united states he come on
[Applause]
the sea field line deposit the sink
filled cup has an incredible lineup and
we're certainly pleased again to be able
to host such an incredible event so I'd
like to get a few thoughts from the
players and I will start with the winner
of the st. Louis rapid and blitz he's
been an ambassador for the Chess Club
virtually since its inception the
longest-running player of all the top
grandmasters here so I'd like to start
with you Hikaru if you will
Magnus is here what what are your
thoughts about what do you thoughts
about what Magnus brings the same feel
Cup yeah well I think both Magnus and
LaVon played here the first year as well
along with my cell phone
but I think Magnus is world champion and
any tournament that he's not in
generally it's not viewed in the same
same way as a tournament that he
competes in so I think if you can play
in a field with Magnuson win a
tournament it's very special so I think
that it's gonna be a very interesting
event and yeah Magnus is the best right
now so I think well I'll just try to do
our best and finish ahead of them well
Fabiano we know that you have a match
that you will be playing against Magnus
in a few months
what does it mean to edge him out here
since it's this is the next tournament
here are the Sinquefield Cup I think
regardless of the match I'd like to win
this tournament I mean it's a very
special event with all the top players
in the world and I'm motivated to do as
well as I can
Magnus we've been talking about you
what does the sink feel cup-winning the
sink filled cup mean to you yeah it's
been it's been a long time coming
I have I won the first one then then
haven't since so I hope to do better
this year and I don't see fighting words
Vichy I like some representation from
someone who hasn't gotten ahold of the
title yet what are your thoughts about
competing for the title this year well
has Jeanne and LexA pointed out several
times to me the no repeat winner so fast
I'd like to maintain that tradition and
hopefully it'll be me Wesley you won you
won a couple years ago but it seems like
it's gotten more difficult since what
are your thoughts coming into this one
your your passion for winning this year
you know hopefully one of us can read a
second time
LaVon your past winner your thoughts
coming into this this year as well your
desire to win this event last year
managed to be the first one to win the
World Cup twice so I think that's a good
tendency so yeah I really look forward
to tournaments played terribly in the
gym blades so something to fight for
Sergei your thoughts on this tournament
as well and trying to win it well of
course I will try to do my best and last
year I played 12 here and I hope to try
to play at least as good as last year
Alex you're not necessarily considered a
favorite to win this event what do you
have to do in order to put your name on
the winner's trophy I actually feel
quite strange in this building because
of its name I believe it's called cause
the Hall of Fame and I feel like for me
there's there should be a separate
building called the Hall of Shame
but nevertheless yes I will quote in
Sergei will try to do my best
[Applause]
Chakri are is your first time in the
United States and you came oh so close
to winning the previous event the st.
Louis rapid in blitz just one game may
be decided everything your thoughts
about playing in the same field cup for
the very first time and it is very nice
to start rapid blitz I play good I mean
and now I want to play not bad in
classical tournaments yeah is well okay
I will try to play good chest
I don't think about results because
cousins yeah try to play good chest okay
Maxim you finally tasted victory at this
event you know what it's like to win and
yeah you're the defending champion
you're gonna have a little bit of a
target on your back what are your
thoughts about trying to repeat as
champion well I don't think I'm the only
one who's gonna have a target on his
back I think all 10 of us well but of
course I mean I have very sweet memories
of of last year and as I say the second
time time taste is even better than the
first
Fabiana I want to go back to you because
we have a lot of press here we have
Sports Illustrated HBO is a special
interest in this tournament because of
the match that you will be playing it's
madness soon does a victory here mean
anything for London well I think a
victory here means a lot but I don't
know if it has any direct correlation to
the match I mean I think that once we
get to London will probably be
forgetting all the past results and just
be focusing on the match itself but a
win and any top tournament especially
here in st. Louis would mean a lot to me
Magnus I'd like to address the same
question to you
there's a victory here mean anything as
far as London is concerned well not for
me but I think Fabi needs to win the
tournament to get to London being being
the grand chess to refine a lot to world
championship
[Applause]
your thoughts on that Fabiano you need
you need to win the event well I think
the last few months I have generally won
tournaments in which Magnus is playing
in so III meant I didn't mean to trash
talk I meant to just state something
factual it was meant to yeah but no
obviously obviously you can he's proved
many times so you can win tournaments
with with me in them so that was that
was not a point at all all right things
are getting hot in here I will open up
the floor to any questions from the
press
Mike Klein I know you always have a
question start with you thanks Maryse
Mike Lynch Escom I saw a lot of you guys
looking at the book in front of you and
a lot of you have had books written
about you but who would be your ultimate
author to write your definitive game
collection who would you like to have
write the definitive volume on your
games and you know as many of you don't
want to respond can anyone want to take
on that one who who do you want to write
your best game collection either myself
or no one I mean I cannot envision
anyone else starting to do this because
you see in many cases people comment
somebody's game but they don't know it
really circumstances in the game and
also the story coming to the game
only a player truly remembers this very
moment in which round and what kind of
mood he has so I think we have to force
the players to write write the books not
the shadow authors as we have it in many
cases anyone disagree with this
sentiment we're gonna get the same
answer
III want that will will write a book
about me I don't lie it's give you
kidding
of course you killings and galleys to
write a book about you why do you want a
nice Giri to write this book oh because
he likes talking with imagine so many
funny things what about you garry
kasparov not giri but a Gary yeah Gary
because he's yeah I mean I think just
Gary because he's written so many books
like the predecessors and other
collections so he does a lot of great
analysis and he I mean at least up to
this point I think most people would
consider him the best player ever so it
was just be interesting to see his take
Magnus no I I mean I don't care like I
think people who actually would
understand but I would pick Christian it
sounds like an inside joke
Lexi yeah I'm a bit of a sadist
I think Magnus would be so pissed off
having to to work on something
I'll pick him
where's would you pay a lot where's the
guy who writes a book about us it will
be called my great successors instead oh
you'd be intersting Gary is already
written quite a bit about you I know
from just from annotating games you
played him in a match Gary your choice I
think if Gary was write a book it will
be called inglourious basterds not easy
for me to write some books because not
enough good games I think ok I think if
it will be some chance I I hope my
friend is ralph Mahmoud of evil write
about me
look Ralph is here every any questions
when the general press no all right well
with that we are going to get to the
closing part of the program I've been
handed the pairings for round 1 and this
is most important for the players to
know who they will be playing so for
round 1 the player I call first will
have white Levon Aronian will play
Sergei Kuryakin Maxime varela gras will
face Magnus Carlsen Hikaru Nakamura
faces off against Vishwanath on Anand
check remedy route plays Wesley so and
Fabiano Caruana faces off against
Alexander Gris Chuck I'd like to mention
also these books that you see in front
of you it is really a special honor for
me you should have seen us we were like
kids in a candy store the co-authors of
this book that included Yasha Sara Juan
Jennifer Shahadah Alejandra Ramirez Tati
Barbra here are Mahamaya and myself and
we worked on this putting together five
years off this glorious tournament and
it was a labor of love and telling you
is very special it come
together and we did not see it until
just a couple of days ago and we were
told it was here and we were jumping up
and down like somebody had said the
baby's here the babies and and I wanted
a signal I want an autograph from
everybody I understand I need one of
those are for my co-authors as well it
is a special book really well done you
got to give credit to Dan Lucas and
Paige and Emily and everybody who really
put this work of art together and we
hope you will get your copy of it
because it is something that we wrote as
a lasting homage to this great
tournament and to the sing fields who
have made this possible we want to thank
you one more time
for your incredible generosity
[Applause]
the Ziegfeld Cup is the final leg and
the grand chest toward the wild-card is
Magnus he's going to throw a monkey
wrench into the standings because
they're players who are looking to get
to London so this tournament is
extremely important right now
Hikaru Nakamura leads the chase but
there are others who are giving chase so
that will be the drama that is set up
for this event it will be exciting
there'll be nine days of amazing chess
we will be calling it you'll be getting
live commentary as we mentioned from the
crew it'll be in Russian 192 countries
fans gearing up to see what is going to
happen at this spectacular event we're
looking forward to it it will start at
12:50 that is the broadcast 1250 Central
time local time and it's going to be so
much fun
branches' Torg don't miss it we'll be
there and I want to thank you all for
joining us good night everyone
[Applause]
[Music]